all right major developments this is a
big night tonight in the Russia
investigation now the big breaking news
the house Intel committee has now ended
what has been a 14 month investigation
into this phase of the Russian probe and
it's now starting to release details of
what it has uncovered this is the only
in this particular case on collusion
we still have FISA abuse uranium one the
a masking scandal and of course the
Clinton bought and paid for dossier
that's not included tonight
here are the takeaways from the house
Intel committee there is zero evidence
let me repeat none no evidence showing
any sort of collusion between the Trump
campaign and Russia by the way I hope
robert muller and his merry band of
democratic partisans and donors and
witch hunters are all watching tonight
their investigation should be shut down
immediately the Deputy Attorney General
rod Rosenstein he needs to be
investigated we'll explain that he's
rushing to Muller's defense saying that
the special counsel is quote not an
unguided missile and Rosenstein is
trying to cover himself because
tonight's brand-new information proves
that Muller is in and has been in a
giant witch-hunt
now also tonight the media the Democrats
this is what you've got to take away for
this this has been going on for nearly
18 months and they have been lying to
you they have perpetuated one of the
biggest hoaxes in American history we'll
have more on that in a minute but here
the other key findings from the GOP
members on the house Intel committee
there is a pattern of Russian attacks
against America's key allies in Europe
Russian hackers use social media in
2015-2016 as we have been telling you to
sow political discord within the United
States President Obama was warned in
2014 he did nothing to stop Vladimir's
Russia even though he was warned
specifically that this was happening and
the committee agrees with the
intelligence community's overall
assessment on Russia interference but
they find that Vladimir Putin did not
have a preference for candidate Donald
Trump now congressional Republicans are
also making very clear and this part is
important the only part of the
investigation that is closed regarding
Russia collusion that's it they will
still be Pro
what is unresolved issues involving the
a masking scandal FISA abuses and of
course the Clinton phony bought and paid
for Russian dossier and also tonight and
this is also a major development Sarah
Carter shall join us reporting and our
other sources confirming to this show an
explosive revelation about the former
Obama Director of National Intelligence
James clapper now clapper allegedly
leaked to fake News CNN information that
then president-elect Donald Trump and
then President Barack Obama were briefed
about a part in the phony dossier that
claims of course that Russians have
compromising information on well then
president-elect Trump and sources are
also telling Sarah Carter tonight the
clapper was in contact with CNN's Jake
Tapper at roughly the same time that CNN
published a report about president-elect
Trump and President Obama being briefed
about the dossier now if you remember
this created a huge massive firestorm
and it helped lay the groundwork for the
media's never-ending hysteria breathless
Trump Russia collusion conspiracy theory
that they have been pushing ever since
and sources are also telling us tonight
clapper was either CNN's original source
or the confirming source about the
report on the dossier what's even more
pathetic and more sleazy is that after
allegedly leaking information to CNN
well clapper then put out a statement
back in January of 2017 it reads in part
well this evening I had the opportunity
to speak with president-elect Donald
Trump to discuss recent media reports
about our briefing last Friday I express
my profound dismay at the leaks that
have been appearing in the press and we
both agree they are extremely corrosive
and damaging to our national security
clapper was lying through his teeth he
was one of the leakers and since then by
the way the former Director of National
Intelligence he has been doing
everything and anything possible to prop
up this phony
Clinton bought and paid for dossier
watch this respect to the dossier itself
the key thing is doesn't matter who paid
for it it's what what the dossier said
and the extent to which it was it's it's
corroborate or do not now we reached out
to James clapper for a statement he were
for fake news CNN on Sara's report and a
spokesperson declined declined to
comment but he did note that Sara's
story appears to be about leaking
information that was not classified or
sensitive so clapper is not outright
denying it which tells you pretty much
everything you need to know we have for
over a year been out here almost an
island unto ourselves as we've been
uncovering this scandal and telling you
as shocking as what is being exposed is
only the tip of the iceberg now the
House Intelligence Committee 14 months
is still conducting very important
investigations they have nothing to do
with Donald Trump but they do have to do
with unmasking at an unprecedented level
unprecedented use of the FISA law and
FISA abuses and of course the Clinton
bought and paid for fake news dossier
this is only the beginning you've been
lied to for well over a year now back to
the other key findings from the
Republicans on the House Intelligence
have lied to you there is no Trump
Russia collusion take a look at this
disgraceful coverage as a means of
remembering what we've been saying a
dizzying 24 hours and the Russian
investigation no longer just inching
toward the president this morning it is
more like careening I think this is a
potentially more dangerous situation
than Watergate and we're at a very
dangerous moment and that's because we
are looking at the possibility that the
President of the United States and those
around him during an election campaign
colluded with a hostile foreign power to
undermine the basis of our democracy
Donald Trump is afraid a political
hurricane is out there at sea for him
we'll call it hurricane vladimer if you
will the whole Russian thing this is
evidence of willingness to commit
collusion
there's outright treason I mean there is
no question that what he is doing is
give the aid and comfort to the enemy
John Friedman said the election hacking
is at the caliber of a Pearl Harbor or a
9/11 to agree with that I completely
agree with that Donald Trump now since
at the threshold of impeachment the only
one who had anything to do with Russia
that tried to propagate false Russian
information was Hillary her bought and
paid for Russian dossier anyone with
half a brain could see that there was no
collusion
now tonight the media in this country
should be apologizing to you the
American people for spreading outright
lies misinformation propaganda for over
a year now Democrats are in the same
boat as the media they look like
complete and total and utter fools
tonight and leading the way of course is
the ranking Democrat on the House
Intelligence Pyrrha CTV MSNBC Adam
Schiff take a look at this painful and
this pathetic evolution on so-called
Trump Russia collusion that we now know
never happened and doesn't exist what do
you got hard well Chris yeah Chris
unfortunately I can't go into the
evidence that's a big you can't reveal
you know I can't reveal that Chris of
course there's one thing to say there's
evidence there's another thing to say we
can prove this or prove it beyond a
reasonable doubt or there's enough
evidence to bring to a grand jury for
purposes of a criminal indictment I
don't think we can say anything
definitively at this point we are still
at the very early stage of the
investigation last March you said you
had more than circumstantial evidence of
treasonous collusion with Russia what
specifically were you referring to and
please be specific because if it's true
I do believe Americans have the right to
know a year later what that is
certainly said that there's ample
evidence of collusion I've never used
the word treason
only Steve Bennett has used that word
but if you look at the the facts that
are already in the public domain they're
pretty damning that's it
oh the the evidence and the public of it
you have no evidence and shift knew the
entire time there was no collusion yet
he went on TV some 250 times since the
inauguration and lied his face off
congressman Schiff is the epitome of a
left-wing partisan hack then of course
there's President Obama like we have
been telling you house Intel committee
Republicans are finding out well he did
nothing to stop Russian election
interference now congressman Devin Nunez
he started warning then President Obama
about Russian an election interference
in 2014
Obama ignored every single warning sign
here's a headline from noon s an op-ed
that he wrote in The Washington Times
and he writes you know the bear out
there okay that means Russia in the
house Intel chair goes on to detail the
direct threat that was posed by Putin
and the Russians this is 2014 and what's
worse is that while all this Russian
interference was beginning to happen and
was happening Obama just before the
election tried to shame then candidate
Donald Trump telling them to stop
whining about an election possibly being
rigged because that could never happen
remember this there is no serious person
out there who would suggest somehow that
you could even you could even rig
America's elections in part because
they're so decentralized and the numbers
of votes involved there's no evidence
that that has happened in the past or
that there are instances in which that
will happen this time and so I divided
mr. Trump to stop whinin and go try to
make his case to get votes yet no
serious person could ever believe it oh
and tell Hillary lawston you needed a
big a excuse then we'll believe it
Democrats should be ashamed of
themselves tonight all of this new
information is
revealing what they really really are
all about total frauds partisan hacks
they don't care what they put the
country through for what 18 months now
Democrats had the opportunity Oh bomb ax
had the opportunity to stop Russia and
then after their candidate lost oh it
couldn't happen but it did happen
because then it was about deal Ajith
amaizing and smearing president Trump to
divert attention away from what really
happened even though Obama said it could
never happen the truth is now finally
all coming out and this is only the
start I told you this was the year of
the boomerang there's a lot that still
needs to be investigated we will stay on
it it will be investigated we do know
the Obama administration we know they
were unmasking members of the Trump
campaign at an unprecedented level and
of course Trump campaign associate and
then of course is the Clinton bought and
paid for dossier that's we still need to
get to the truth on that Hillary Clinton
didn't care about paying for false
information Russian government lies to
influence an election the FBI took that
completely unverified dossier they have
a legal and an ethical and protocol
obligation to do it themselves they lie
to a FISA judge they never verified they
never corroborated they never told the
judge clinton paid for it you know to
get a warrant to spy on a member of the
opposition party campaign during an
election year and remember the Grassley
gram memo the dossier will made up the
bulk of the FISA application and the
former deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe
testifying no dossier there wouldn't
have even been a FISA application they
never verified they never checked they
didn't care this is the biggest abuse of
power scandal in the history of this
country it is the biggest corruption
scandal and it's only beginning sit
tight be patient I know for a fact more
information is coming